[Music]
We want to look at
something. So, come on over
here. Okay. Right now, you two in
particular are
um getting a little more dynamic
understanding of where the center is,
how to ground vector and how to project.
Okay, it's a step you have to get there.
Now we want to
understand
consciously what I had you just zeroing
in on feeling. Okay.
Um you want definitely a
kinesthetic sense of what you're doing.
That has to be there. That's why we
prioritized it. But you also consciously
want to
understand what you're doing. Why is it
working? Etc.
because in tactical situations that
might become necessary. Okay. So let us
we're going to do the following
discovery
learning. Okay. We have
our cross.
And what you'll
notice is at the
uh
180 energy that's coming in from UK, if
you project it back on the
180, it's
doable and you get a kind of violent
uh reaction when the rebounding energy
overrides their yong aspect. But if you
pay
attention, while that exact contact
moment is kind of percussive and
violent, there's not much displacement
factor to it. Uh, and the reason for
that is because of how we're generating
the rebounding energy. So the ukas yang
aspect is coming into us and for us to
go back forward it has to continually
come into us. So there's a kind of
energy leakage that is happening because
we never go to the bracing angle where
we start just shoving it all this way.
as we're moving this way, there's still
some of their yong aspect coming through
us otherwise we're not doing it. Okay?
And that leads to that
delay. When we rotate the cross so to
speak, we are very interested in these
diagonals. Okay?
And if we call this
like the highest yong, as you start to
move around, you're going to enter
towards the yin
phase. Okay? And this has an impact on
how much displacement we get on their
base when we're coq projecting. Okay?
What you'll notice is as you
as you start to move this way, it
becomes less violent, less percussive at
the contact point. But because we're not
subject to that internalization of what
we're projecting, you actually get
better projection out at this
45. Okay?
And what we doing here when we spiral
rotate the UK is not going this way and
then I hit them at that way is that we
are actually bringing the UK this way.
And so we're really hitting them at the
90 even though it's a 45. Okay? And
that's key. And we're doing that every
time because this is UK's path in in
iikido.
Okay.
Um,
however, because we're at this 45,
there's still some of this pure yang
uh coming towards us. There's still some
energy going this way. And as we come
around, that pure yong starts to get
less and less. Okay? And so when we do
when we hit we bring UK around to this
uh 90° and we hit at this 90° you're
going to see that there's not as much
displacement value uh as we're coming
along and then it'll get decreased as we
start now projecting along or toward or
with that 180°ree yong. uh because we
don't have the oppositional energy to
ground off of and to project with. So
this is going to be a weaker energy uh
line and this will be also a weaker
energy line. This will be the weakest.
Um there'll be little projection here.
Okay. And then it'll start to go back
towards its uh yang phase. And uh here
again at this 45 as we brought their
energy around you will repeat the cycle.
Okay. Again you are actually projecting
at a 90° angle but they're at a 45°
angle to that 180 line. And here is
another major uh 90° projection
point. And then same thing will happen.
it'll get a little weaker and a little
weaker and then you're back where you
have that kind of weirdness where you're
both projecting what you're
internalizing. Okay. And this is this
these are uh the key points. This is
where we here in sensient iikido this is
all things being equal. We will either
project here right or right or left side
here or here or we'll bring you past the
6:00 and we will be at one of these
depending you're left or right. Okay.
Careful never if you're if you're
bringing them around this way
counterclockwise careful that's about
your limit of where you can go on the
90. Uh the these are a waste of time.
there's not enough uh internalized yong
aspect that you can actually utilize and
you start to get into your momentum
throws down here. Okay. So, we're going
to do some discovery learning so you
could feel that. But you're going to
consciously
um I want you to keep with the
kinesthetic awareness of what you're
doing, but I want you to consciously
understand where my feet need to be in
relation to their stance to capitalize
upon the energy benefits of this angle.
Okay, we'll work with this angle first,
but we'll do all these so you'll feel
the difference. Okay. Um, and then we'll
task ourselves
with making their line of gravity go
outside their base of support. Okay. And
so again here, this one, if we look at
at these angles from that task, line of
gravity outside the base of support,
it's very easy for the UK to put their
base of support back under because they
just walk backwards. But when they're
being brought this way, uh, the line of
gravity will fall outside the base of
support more easily and because they're
moving forward, they can't really get
themselves into that position. Okay. Uh,
so let's look at this now. All right.
So first to uh demonstrate how because
of that uh
simultaneous internalization with the
projection there's a kind of uh
sluggishness to what's happening because
there's a I mean in essence there's a
kind of not all energy is going in in
one direction okay and the oppositional
force is simultaneously
being internalized as it is being
outvalued and it leads to some
weirdness. Then you also will see that
all all he has to do is is walk
backwards and his base of support is
there. So we'll work on that 180. He's
just going to come in and we'll just
do and and you could see like there's a
kind of and then the percussion happens.
Do you see? And then all he's doing is
walking back out. He He'll have his
balance. It's not
that difficult to do. Okay. And we'll
have Virginia feel what I'm talking
about right
here. Okay. I'll have you guys try.
Okay. uh with the line of gravity aspect
of it. If you pay she yes she is
preoccupied with the rebounding force
but
um and we do do that a lot but it's not
a combination of preoccupy preoccupation
with the rebounding energy plus the
kazushi. Okay, those aren't the same
thing. And so you'll see that yes, she's
preoccupied, but her line of gravity is
constantly inside her base of support.
Okay? And so the more athletic people,
uh, they can recover from that
preoccupation with the rebounding energy
quite quickly. Okay? Um, like like I
know Ronin is basically you you get one
step and a half a step and he's back in
the game. Okay? someone super athletic
and coordinated is going to be able to
do. All right. So now we'll go to the
90. And so that means I have to bring
her into the curve. Okay. And when I
bring her into the curve and I preoccupy
her with her intention, like her initial
assault intention, uh her initial 180
degree
uh yong aspect, and I start to bring it
into a turn. Stay there, please.
Her base is very
narrow. So, I only need her line of
gravity to get out a tiny bit. And
because she's going forward, she's not
going to be able to keep her base
underneath her line of gravity like when
she's going backwards. Okay? And you'll
see that there's none of that
sluggishness where she's came in. It's
all being internalized until it goes
back out. Okay? It's more it's more
immediate and you can see she's more
stumbling
etc. We're just doing
small
projections so you could feel that it
doesn't matter which way you
go. The hand work doesn't
matter. Okay. So, I'll have you feel
that 90, that first 45 degree angle.
Chris. Okay. So now, yes, the maximum
yong
aspect that I can internalize and
rebound out is the 180. However, as I
said already, you lose some of it
because you're simultaneously
internalizing what you're trying to
outvalue. when we go to the 45 degree
angle as we bring them into the into the
spiral uh I get a lot of that
oppositional energy the yang aspect that
I'm
internalizing and I don't have the
problem of inter internalizing
simultaneously what I'm trying to
outvalue plus I have the benefit that
his base is narrow to the projection
line and his line of gravity falls out
easily outside that base of support. As
we start
going around the clock, you get less of
the 180° yong aspect. So, there's less
to internalize. So, then there'll be
less to rebound, and that's what I want
you to feel. Okay? So, you're going to
still have the line of gravity based of
support benefit as you come around on
the spiral, but your projection ability
or your projection potential is lower
because you're now less oppositional to
the yong aspect. Here's the true 180.
Okay. So, we going to do the 90 and
you'll feel how Yeah. less less energy
coming coming out. Okay. Does he still
lose his balance? Yes. But there's way
less energy on my
part. You you can feel that. Okay. So, I
want you guys to try that. Move around
the clock. And we're we're going this
way. So, as we move to 8:00, we are less
oppositional to the original young
aspect. So, there'll be less to
internalize. There'll be less to
project. Okay? And you'll feel ah it's
kind of leaking out all over the place.
Okay? So, I'm bringing her into the
spiral and I hit this angle there. And
you're going to feel like I'm I'm having
to push more with my hands. I'm going
have I have to do more external stuff as
opposed to here. Boom. There's not
there's less on my hands. As I start
coming out here, she's going with me. Uh
don't stop like don't don't act for me.
Okay? You you have to evolve past this
need to perform. Do you understand? All
you have to do is grab and push. That's
all you do. And you keep your grip.
Don't try to predict what I'm doing.
There we go. And you can see that now
I'm really just accelerating her. And
you'll get the benefit of the athletic
people will be able to just uh get their
base back under their line of gravity.
So, we'll switch roles. Your knees
jacked
up. Okay. You're going to take me to
that
corner. And I don't ever really go off
balance. Does that make sense? If you do
this 45, you'll see the line of gravity
benefit. We're here and yes, it goes
outside my base of support. Okay. And so
a lot of times in
iikido, we we think the
acceleration because now I'm going with
the 180, you see, is beneficial. But
there's just no kazushi in it for
anybody that's athletic or is actually
fighting with you. So, uh, if she's
going to take me that way again, okay,
to that
corner and you're you're the second you
feel it, I'm off. Do you see? So, that's
where I can feel her accelerating me.
And you'll see that's where people just
change release.
Whereas if she goes to this way, by the
time I feel it, it already got me. Okay,
make sense? Okay, try it.
Right. And
so, not only do you lose that line of
gravity benefit, like you're immediately
out of it, okay? and you're moving away
from the acceleration throws. You have
to understand like why do we go to the
acceleration throws? We go to the
acceleration throws because we don't
have the ability to internalize the yong
aspect. So, we get out of the way of the
yong aspect. Okay? Uh meaning like I I
could be here all the time and do that.
I don't have the inability to do that.
Why don't I do it is because I want
these other benefits. But it doesn't
mean that I'm going to go to these
angles because
uh they don't work. And I'm definitely
not having to go to those angles because
I can't internalize the yong aspect.
Okay. So the the most yin angle and the
most accelerating angle is you let it
all go by and you go you go that way.
Okay. Um
again you the
nag we doing this and this behavior that
the that the UK does is uh cultural like
the guy told you to hold on and you held
on. Okay. So you're here and you're
like but no one does that.
Okay.
So the uk that is here feels that and
you're just here.
Okay.
Um so it's a no no. Okay. And want to
understand why do we tend to do it? Why
don't we want to do it? Okay. Is the is
the reason being. So I
understand that you are here and then
you're moving him but that's not
projection. That's just you getting out
of the
way and pushing him with the inertia
that was coming in. So you gota you got
to understand what I mean when I say
your projection potential goes down.
It's not that he can't be made to go
that way. You see that? It's is he being
made to go a certain angle through the
rebounding energy or not? Okay. And when
we take him here, there's abs there's no
rebounding energy. There's just a new
energy that's happening. Okay, try it.
So to make this point, if I'm here,
boom, my arms don't move. If I do the
other one, my arms don't move. He
doesn't go anywhere. There's no
rebounding energy in that. Okay. And now
we'll come back up. So when you bring
them around this way, you you you can
see that you're starting the
new 180. It's just like she came in from
this angle. Okay. So when you're
bringing her around this way, the energy
that's coming back now can be grounded
and projected again. Do do you guys see
that?
So here's the max, but it has that
weirdness that you're simultaneously
internalizing as you're trying to
outvalue. Here I am just simply uh
internalizing and it doesn't have that
simultaneity. So you'll get the
projection plus the benefit of her
narrow base. And here you're absorbing
less yong aspect because you're now 90
degrees to its original intention.
Right? And as we come back to these
angles, there's no there's none. Okay?
It's often because you're going with it.
And then this would be the worst one.
But as you bring her back around, then
she's coming back forward. Do you see?
And that now is what
you can project again. And that's why we
use that angle, that angle, and we're
just constantly working those diagonals
as we go around. Okay. So, try this one.
All right. I don't have the mic on.
We're just We got to make this detail.
We're running out of time. Okay. To get
someone around
6:00 and to be going that
way. This is and this is where I want to
go with this eventually. The I adhesion
hand now becomes relevant. When you're
on the positive side of the circle, they
can both be projection hands, which is
where you guys are at, but you need to
get the adhesion part. Okay. So, as he's
coming in, this hand has to start
adhering and be able to bring him around
the horn, so to speak. Okay? And it's
that energy that now gives the
projection energy. Okay? So, you can't
go
here and do two projection energies
because that's going to be still y. It's
going to be an extension of those
problem angles. Okay? So this hand has
to go this way and then that man can go
that way. So you have to have the I
adhesion plus the ku projector. Okay. So
let's try it again.